when my girls came home they were really
unsettled so what we decided to do is
every day we would sit down and talk
about what's happening on the corner
virus and importantly what to expect
what to expect and this notion of I
don't know for sure but they so what I'm
looking for has helped people enormously
because given a road map it's been
almost three weeks since President Trump
issued his 15 days to slow the spread
recommendations urging everyone to stay
at home and only leave for essential
business those recommendations have now
been extended through the entire month
of April which leaves a lot of
uncertainty for everyone as we grow
increasingly more concerned with our
health and well-being as well as our
financial stability by ordering every
non-essential business to close the
economy came to a crashing halt spring a
two trillion dollar stimulus package
another four trillion dollars of
spending from the Federal Reserve and
the highest rate of unemployment this
country has ever seen while the health
care industry works on defeating this
virus infection and death rates are
constantly changing based on incoming
data every day more and more people go
without work and paychecks propelling
the debate of how important the
stability of the economy is to public
health not just the importance of public
health to the economy today we're gonna
look at that argument from both a health
care perspective and an economists
perspective we're going to be talking
the models used by governments to
determine whether to shut down the
economy the question of balancing
economics and public health and when we
finally get back to normal
[Music]
picking it off the dr. Bob Walker his
professor and chair of the department of
medicine at the University of California
San Francisco and the author of about
300 articles and six books his past
president of the Society of hospital
medicine and past chair of the American
Board of Internal Medicine dr. Walker
thanks so much for joining the show I
want to start by asking you some basic
biological questions about crota virus
let's start with the sort of conflicting
messaging we've been seeing about face
masks are they a good idea or a bad idea
at this point I think the science has
evolved in the last couple weeks spent I
think we now better understand that
people can have the virus and be
asymptomatic and be shedding virus at
that time and so now that we understand
that it is I believe marginally safer if
everybody wears face masks out in public
they give people do it the it will
become D stigmatized the way it has in
many Asian countries it'll be weird it's
gonna take a lot of getting used to but
I think while the virus is out there in
the communities it seems like a prudent
thing to recommend I also want to ask
about the the hand-washing so um
obviously we're all doing it all of our
hands are raw and bloody so when it
comes to hand-washing
how why 20 seconds is there something
magical about 20 seconds versus 15 or 25
not magical there have been sort of
these funny studies where they look at
people's hands that have soiled or germs
on them and and watch them for various
periods of time to see which ones
essentially guarantee that your hands
will be cleaned of viruses and
20-seconds happens to be right and it
just happens to line up with singing
happy birthday twice so let's talk about
the hospitalization rates for for folks
with corona virus so what percentage of
folks with corona virus end up going to
the hospital what percentage of those
people end up having to go to an ICU
what percentage of the ICU people end up
on a ventilator or those coincident and
what percentage of people on ventilators
actually end up surviving
okay how long we got this it's a lot of
the answer back then depends on the
population of patients as we know we
know that older people and people with
other diseases before they got sick with
front of iris do worse so for example
the very high mortality rates and I see
rates in Italy a partly related in fact
that was an older population
but if you take all comers about 80% of
people who get the virus do just fine
they in fact some of them we now know
are asymptomatic through the entire time
but most of them all have a flu-like
illness recover fully and be fine
about 20% of people will get sick enough
and a decent percentage of them 15 to 20
percent of all comers will need to go to
the hospital of those somewhere around
1/4 to 1/3 again depending on the
overall health of the population might
need to go to an intensive care unit not
everybody who goes to an ICU needs to be
on a mechanical ventilator needs to be
intubated and ventilated but if you
can't breathe without it you do and then
the overall death rate nationally in the
u.s. is around 1% of all people that get
the get the illness if you were
unfortunate enough to need to go on a
mechanical ventilator in the ICU the
studies vary but they on the low side
the mortality rate is 50% on the high
side some of the early studies from
China showed a mortality rate closer to
90% so not everybody can get sick enough
to be on a ventilator dies but it's a
it's a bad thing and and the outcomes
are at best 50/50 so looking across the
country obviously the hotspot right now
is New York we've seen emerging hotspots
in places like New Orleans and Detroit
but in San Francisco you've--you've
suggested that the curve has been rather
successfully flattened in Seattle it
looks like the curve has been rather
successfully flattened what do you think
is the difference between cities like
New York Detroit and San Francisco or
Seattle it's hard to know fully and I
suspect that multiple factors are at
play but here in San Francisco there was
a concerted amount of action by both
government leaders and I think very
importantly corporate leaders too they
saw what happened in China they saw what
was happening in Italy and they took it
very seriously they believed the science
and I think the science is relatively
clear that the best chance that we had
to to stay safe was early an aggressive
action and the action we're sheltering
in place the action was avoiding close
contact the action was hand washing
things
and so here in in the Bay Area as early
as March 5th leaders of the big
companies that was a Google Facebook
Salesforce and others basically told all
their employees to stay home and work
from home now
they're advantaged in doing that because
their employees are all digital and they
all have ways of working from home it's
not so easy if you're an uber driver
you're working in manufacturing in other
places but that was as early as March
mid March 16th the the mayor of San
Francisco and the mayors of the five
counties around San Francisco all issued
a sheltering in place Porter and the
Governor of California did the same
thing on march 19th those were earlier
than any large areas in the country so I
think it was all of that and I think
people did it people just kind of
believed that this was real we better
pay attention I think part of that was
being on the west coast we're
particularly close to China we have a
very large Asian population you saw what
happened in China we kind of took it
very seriously and the second reason I
think is Seattle was the first part of
the United States to get hammered and
San Francisco and Seattle or pretty or
almost Sister Cities they're very
similar in many in many ways and we saw
that you say if it can happen in Seattle
can happen here so I think it's and then
there's just some luck I think that you
know New York may have gotten unlucky
there are places where it just breaks
out and and even if you did all the
right stuff you're still gonna have a
big problem but I think those actions
really did make a difference so dr.
Walker in just a second I want to ask
you about some of the modeling that's
being used to justify the entire
economic shutdown we'll get to that in
just one second but first let's talk
about the fact that we're spending an
enormous amount of time online right now
and that is like AI hackers paradise
that are looking for your information
and now would be a great time for them
to steal it from you this is why you
need a VPN and you know the VPN I trust
is expressive VPN for the best online
protection possible I've been talking
about expressvpn on this show for so
long you'll already understand why
encrypting your network data is
important but if you haven't done it
that is your fault so stop making it
your fault instead go get expressvpn
you might be thinking security threats
don't affect you personally not using
expressvpn it's like leaving your front
door unlocked every time you go out
nothing might happen for years when a
break-in does happen it's pretty
devastating now be a very bad time to
have somebody steal your credit card
number well
the easiest ways to secure your internet
data is with expressvpn you click one
button on your computer or smartphone
and you are now protected so here's the
only question why haven't you gotten
expressvpn yet visit my special link
right now expressvpn comm slash man get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free protect your internet today with
the VPN I trust to keep my data safe
that's expressive VPN calm slash been
expressvpn calm slash been so we've been
relying very heavily on the models to
determine exactly what we ought to do
here one of the questions about the
models has been exactly how far they
extend so the IMA chi model from the
university of washington has been
heavily used as sort of the source for
we're going to experience maybe up to
one hundred and thousand deaths that
model only extends until the very
beginning of august it doesn't take into
account the possibility of a second wave
and that raises questions as to what
exactly the purpose of the the curve
flattening is so on the one hand
obviously we want to flatten the curve
so that we don't exceed the the medical
capacity that is out there for
ventilators or for for ICU beds on the
other hand if there's gonna be a second
wave in the fall and we are all going to
get it and we how do we calculate
exactly when it is worth it to go back
to work considering that the economy is
taking unprecedented hits right now ten
million people unemployed in the last
two weeks yeah it's a brutally difficult
question I I'm not going to accept the
idea that we're all going to get it I
particularly for myself being over 60
I'm in one of the risk groups so I can't
go to sleep at night buying that it's
inevitable the world going to get it I
think what we are trying to do is tamp
this thing down as much as possible so
that hopefully it then dies down during
the summer there's some seasonality
about it so that then when it comes back
in the fall which is likelier than not
we're prepared for it we know what to do
we can immediately institute the kind of
public health measures at this time I
think the instituted on the late side we
can we have widespread testing available
so that we can aggressively find people
that have it early and quarantine them
and isolate them from the rest of the
public and all of this I guess if this
went on forever and we never
found a vaccine then there is a good
chance that ultimately probably we
wouldn't all get it there just thing
called herd immunity then when you reach
a certain amount of the population who's
gotten it and has antibodies it begins
to die out but that's 70 or 80 percent
of the population so that's that's a
pretty nasty vision the hope is we tamp
this thing down over a long enough time
that yes we don't overwhelm the
healthcare system but more importantly
we come up with treatments or vaccines
and can get rid of this thing once and
for all it's one of the difficulties in
the modeling is because so few of the
models extend out a full year and
because there are so many variables it's
difficult to see exactly what the sort
of counterfactuals are in the various
assumptions so you have the the
assumption where we do nothing and 2.2
million people die but it's it's
difficult to see okay we have over the
course of a year not the course of three
months over the course of the year how
many people die if we engage in social
distancing and mask-wearing for people
who are under the age of 60 or 65 people
who are 65 shelter-in-place to the best
of their ability we isolate people who
are in old age homes and have inherent
vulnerabilities what is the
counterfactual to that or lock down for
three months and then do it there are so
many variables it's hard to tell like
what is worth it at this point so what
do you think emerging from this looks
like and when do you think we start to
emerge from from this yeah I mean we
need to put our best minds and our best
models to this to help guide us as to
what the right thing to do is there is
there is no question that a stance like
we now have in California increasingly
around the country that everybody stays
at home and the economy shuts down can't
be our stands forever that can't
possibly work and eventually people
there will be so much harm from that you
begin that way the harm from the virus
against their harm from the economy and
they harm to health from people not
going out and getting health care there
there there are competing demands here
that we've got to be thoughtful about
I'll tell you a quick metaphor for that
which is at UCSF where I work the we
prepared for a New York like surge we
have not seen it we completely canceled
all surgeries essentially unless it was
absolutely a hyper emergency for a
couple of weeks we're now beginning to
open up to do more urgent sir
and that's because we have at some point
you say alright we're not seeing the
same kind of surge we need to take care
of other people and so there are there's
a balancing act that we all have to do
it appears that the best models seem to
say that sometime in the next four to
six weeks and it depends on how
prevalent it is in the community and how
much of a spike you had because you come
down faster if you had a big spike the
rates of the prevalence of the virus
will go down in communities to the point
that we can begin entering a new phase
where we begin to relax some of the
strict standards that we have now begin
to let people go out but the key thing
there is going to be testing and contact
tracing which we haven't done very much
of what yep you know when you have tens
of thousands of cases you can't do
contact tracing it's overwhelming your
system but if you can tamp this down my
analogy is that of a wildfire that you
have tamp down the worst of the wildfire
and now you're out there looking for
embers and you see an ember and it pops
up and you stomp on it and make sure
that it doesn't spread so we can I think
reach that kind of a mode where we've
tamped it down so it's not rampant in
the community hopefully it goes away or
mostly goes away over the summer and by
the time it comes back in the fall we're
ready for it if someone has any symptoms
we immediately test them we're checking
people's temperatures people probably
are still wearing masks and if we find a
case those people get isolated separated
from the community probably or at least
we consider separating from their
families as well and that we can keep
this thing is at a low enough level that
then there is time to go ahead and find
a vaccine and the treatments so given
the variability in the models and given
the fact there was an article in The
Washington Post talking about how even
the White House's estimate a hundred
thousand to two hundred forty thousand
dad it was completely vague we have no
idea over what term even they were
talking though we don't know what the
factors were in coming to to those
statistics so I've been asking sort of a
wide variety people to Ballpark where
they think we are over the next year
given the fact that there seems to be
pretty wide consensus that we're gonna
have to transfer back into the workforce
by mid-may perhaps by by June at the at
the very latest that this cannot last
forever so if that is what happens if we
start to test pea
move people back into circulation
isolate people who are most at risk tell
people to hunker down until there's a
vaccine if they are really truly the
most at risk if we do that what do you
think the numbers look like do you think
it looks like a hundred thousand well I
believe the bottles I think a hundred
thousand it is looking like the minimum
and that is extraordinarily tragic you
think about what that what that means
but it's you know we're seeing New York
and and but New York is just the leading
edge of what we are likely to see in
Detroit New Orleans potentially Florida
a number of other a number of other
cities Illinois and so if it's 90,000
still pretty terrible but I think so it
is a big number my confidence that the
fall will not be as bad as the spring is
that I think I think we're smart enough
to have learned the lessons of this that
it's no longer it's awfully hard to tell
people to disrupt your life and
basically screw up the economy based on
a theory or based on something that's
happening China once it's happened to
New York once it's happened in big
cities I think people get it is that
this is a real this is the real deal I
think we will take the kind of actions I
think science will move quickly I think
we will find treatments and vaccines and
almost as importantly new techno
technology ways to track cases and
follow people there you know the if you
look at what happened it's hard to know
whether the numbers coming out of China
or right but what's happened in Prior
epidemics what could the experience in
Korea for example seems to show that
after that initial spike if everybody
gets their act together we can keep this
thing at bay to a large extent and the
analogy I think the people always say
well there was a big surge in in the
Spanish flu well yes but the Spanish was
think about what they had to do
tracing there were no treatments there
were no vaccines there was no zoom there
was no Netflix there and you're telling
people to stay at home I think our
ability to weather this and act
responsibly and get and communicate
effectively is massively better today
than today than it was 100 years ago
so I don't think the fall will be as bad
as it's been I will be in the sperm
doctor Wachter I want to do a quick
lightning round I have five questions
for you so number one what do you see as
the actual sort of end date for the
crisis well to end it's when when does
life go back to normal either post
vaccine or not and and when do we
actually start to emerge from the from
the the groundhog the groundhog holes
that we've been burrowing and for the
past for the past oh it's it's it's
anybody's guess but I'm guessing that
you know May to June probably mid May is
the best estimate of being able to come
out of our half-hour burrow and get back
to something that resembles more closely
resembles normal is is right and in
terms of when in terms of when we reach
a time that things are truly back to
normal the best estimates for a vaccine
or 12 to 18 months and the minute people
find it it's not trivial to get it into
the arm of 350 million people so you
know you got to think it's it's 18 to 24
months so question number two with all
that time what does America look like in
six months I mean are we still
presumably social distancing is
everybody wearing masks to what what do
you think that that American life looks
like six months from now I think masks
are going to become a norm I don't know
if it'll be quite like Tokyo or other
places in Japan where it is absolutely
the norm but you're gonna see a lot of
people wearing masks I think people are
going to be cleaning their hands
incessantly I think people are gonna
keep a distance from one another until
and that may vary community by community
if there are no cases in your community
it may be reasonable to loosen that a
little bit as long as you have very
active case finding and if you do find a
case then you begin to do the contact
tracing and and those sort of things but
in communities where there still is
virus in the in the zeitgeist I think
you are going to see people walking
around with masks keeping their distance
and cleaning their hands religiously and
I think that's the right thing to do
what should America do what are the big
steps that we can take to prevent the
next pandemic because this obviously is
not the first and it will not be the
last yeah I mean if you look at how well
some of the country the countries in
Asia reacted it was in large part
as they had a playbook that they could
pull off the show and they had a
national strategy for dealing with us
and the national strategy had every
included what should the population be
told and what do they need to do and it
can't be a patchwork of you do it this
way in this city do it this way in this
state it really has to be a national
strategy because this thing permeates
state and city lines it goes to red and
blue states it's got to be a uniform
playbook it has to include a testing
strategy and part of the challenge here
was you know we don't have a way of
getting testing throughout the entire
country so we have to have a rapid-fire
way somebody at CDC has to be able to
obviously with the White House with
health leaders has to be able to push a
button and say there's been an outbreak
in this place and it looks awfully like
coronavirus and here's the PlayBook
let's roll without and I think at least
if it happens in the next five or ten
years I think people will remember this
and believe it happens twenty or thirty
years ago from now people will forget
this and will go through the same drama
I'm afraid so how should we treat the
government of China after this obviously
the government of China not only
prevaricated about the the virus at the
beginning they openly lied to the w-h-o
they said there was no human to human
transmission they knew better obviously
they've been using some of their
propaganda efforts to actually suggest
that the United States put out the virus
how should the world community be
treating China in the aftermath of this
from a health perspective well I think
this shows how interconnected we all are
and I'm not a diplomacy expert so it's
difficult for me to know how we should
treat them but I think what it has made
clear is that we can't completely
isolate from one another the borders are
permeable a virus that starts in China
is going to end up here and vice versa
China China reacted trying to react it
late and and didn't do some of the
things they should have done on the
other hand once they reacted they were
acted with an aggressiveness that I
think probably saved a bunch of lives in
China and may have saved a bunch of
lives around around the world they did
things that we're not capable of doing
and we shouldn't be capable of doing in
terms of what an authoritarian regimen
can do but in some ways I think I can
understand us being
happy with them and that influencing our
relationships on the other hand it just
shows how extraordinarily connected all
the countries are and if we isolate from
one another
it doesn't work the virus gets through
and we'd have to work together better
finally the measures that everybody is
taking you mentioned before that we're
gonna be wearing masks for a while is
there ever a point where where we go
back to full normal meaning like giant
events 60,000 people at baseball games I
sort of think at this point that all
mass events are basically going to be
canceled until there's a vaccine are all
the measures we're taking right now
temporary and permanent uh uh I really
hope they're not permanent my son works
the Atlanta Braves and I can't imagine
that we're never going to go to a
baseball game again that's just that's
too hard to even even imagine
I gotta think that this is a will be
back to something resembling normal in a
couple of years it might be a little
shorter than that I don't think it will
be that much longer than that you think
about the quality of the American
scientific and medical enterprise the
idea that we're not going to be able to
find a vaccine for this I find hard to
believe if we completely put our full
resources full attention to it
I think for a year year and a half
things are going to be pretty weird I
think they are going to they're not
going to be full lockdown like they are
now for the next probably the next month
or two probably two but they're not
going to be normal people are going to
be walking around with masks
people are going to be keeping their
distance and cleaning their hands all
the time but I think we're going to
reach a point in a couple of years where
what things will be back to something
resembling normal well dr. Walker I
really appreciate your time and has it
been saying to folks stay safe in there
because we can't be out there really
appreciate it
[Music]
joining us next is dr. Scott Atlas a
medical doctor senior fellow at Stanford
University's Hoover Institution and a
member of the institution's working
group on healthcare policy his previous
chief of neuro radiology at Stanford
Medical Center is the author of the
leading textbook on MRIs and has written
over 120 scholarly articles dr. Atlas
thanks so much for joining the show
really appreciate your time so let's
start with some questions about the
modeling that's been used so far some
models that I've seen really only go out
a couple of months the the model from
the University of Washington that's been
heavily relied upon that says that we
could see up to a hundred thousand
deaths that only goes up to August I
guess my question with these models is
we are all now locking down for the next
few weeks at a bare minimum in order to
flatten the current for the next few
months but none of these models seems to
extend far beyond that and we've been
told that the vaccines are only gonna be
ready 12 to 18 months from now it's
obviously unrealistic to suggest that we
are going to be locked up for 12 to 18
months in our own homes that's just not
going to be workable so how exactly
should we balance the needs of Public
Health and the needs of the economy in a
time when we are at such a lack for it
for data as to what happens next
yeah I mean this is of course a very
tricky question I would say a couple of
points to understand number one the
models are really just those and like
all projections they're likely to be
wrong no matter how good the people are
they're doing them because there's so
many incoming assumptions that underlie
each projection and it's something very
important to understand because as you
know the definition of a case could be a
positive test only could be a
symptomatic person the testing is very
different and heterogeneous ly
distributed second point is that to to
re-enter I would call I use that word
reenter society I think we're going to
see something first
clearly gradual and secondly there's
going to be a sort of a different way to
look at reentry I make the analogy it's
possible that we will see what people
call a new normal remember after 9/11
everything changed in airport security
we never had that sort of waiting lines
and I used to run up to a plane minutes
before it took off all those things
changed this
might be the same in that at least in
the beginning I think it's very likely
we will need some sort of testing to
permit an allow re-entry and that
testing is likely to be twofold one is
antibody testing which involves a blood
test of some sort and that will say if
you're immune or not meaning you've
already had it and you're you're highly
unlikely to get it again judging from
all biology of previous virus infections
and those people clearly will be safe
and actually fine to re-enter and the
other test might be a test of active
virus presence and I think that's that's
possible and actually easier but
probably less less likely to be done so
I think we will have some sort of
testing at point of entry we will still
have restrictions and most importantly
we will have restrictions and I'm
talking about as we re-enter on the
people who are the vulnerable people
remember the number one goal is to stop
people from dying and it doesn't really
matter if you get a mild version of this
which the overwhelming majority of cases
are mild the question is how to protect
those who are vulnerable and this is the
number one focus and most urgent thing
of any policy so older people
particularly people with underlying
chronic diseases need protection they
need isolation they need meaning
isolation from people who are either
asymptomatic or sick clearly and then
that is going to need testing of people
who deal with those people and those
people the older people who are much
more likely to have a serious illness or
die we're going to need special sort of
re-entry public health formulations so
with all of that set and looking at sort
of the fact that these these models and
studies are not taking into account
really the possibility of a second wave
or the reality that people are going to
re-enter the workforce there are a lot
of skeptics out there who have been kind
of rear
their heads and saying okay well maybe
we could take this for a week but we
can't take this for another two months
and the economy is losing 10 million
jobs every couple of weeks here and we
are going to enter economic levels not
seen since ever in the United States in
terms of unemployment so why not pursue
a policy like like Sweden for example
where we isolate everybody who's over
the age of 60 if you're over the age of
60 or if you have a pre-existing health
condition you're expected to stay in
your house and self isolate everybody
else goes to work everybody else wears
masks every about everybody else social
distances and life goes back to quasi
normal it appears that that may in fact
be what ends up happening after three
months of this is that sort of the plan
that after three months if the summer
knocks this thing down or if the curve
actually flattens that we all go back to
life in that way and if so then what's
the what is the end date of that sort of
thing yeah I sort of think there's going
to be something like that I don't think
it will be okay there's so many parts to
the question I mean one part is how do
we re-enter and who reenters and you
know we are a certain sort of society so
the main thing to get the economy going
is to allow people in the workforce to
get going and as you obviously must
realize people over 65 are not a big
part of the workforce and so it's
clearly less impactful to restrict those
people I do think the testing is going
to be part of this and you know there's
a lot of new tests there are more than
20 tests being worked on some have been
approved even today for antibody testing
we do testing all the time at home and
at points of care for things you know
there are simple pregnancy tests and we
don't have that sort of thing yet but I
envision some sort of like at-home
diabetic people use a blood pinprick
test so I think that to re-enter you
know there's a public health concern and
there's an individual concern and the
working economy is critical there's as
you are alluding to a huge cost to
individuals and to really sickness but
death when there's a depression sort of
economic situation this is
not going to go on I think we have to
realize a couple things number one the
isolation policies actually work and are
working and this is a message that I
think people don't quite understand yes
more and more people are dying but the
rate of increase of deaths is slowing
all over the world and we have to
realize that there are causes for
optimism this is reality not just panic
mode and so as we see these death rates
the increase in deaths go down which
they are eventually we're going to get a
hands on that this is a virus there's
fundamental biology to understand and we
are going to have enough immunity we are
going to allow and it's actually
beneficial to allow more people to
mingle given that the overwhelming
majority are not going to die and the
overwhelming majority are going to have
a mild or symptom course we needed
so-called herd immunity because there's
a natural way to eliminate viruses like
this and that is by natural immunity and
yes you're right we don't have an
immunization we won't have an
immunization as we re-enter but the
immunization technology is very good
we'll have it in theory projections are
at least by early this coming year maybe
sooner we don't know but there's going
to be a reentry and it's essential for
health reasons as well as simply the
economic survival of individuals and
families so realistically speaking it
seems as though a lot of the press
that's being done dr. Atlas on on on
this sort of stuff from the White House
from other from other folks who talk
about it has focused on on this sort of
idea that we're all going to avoid the
disease but that obviously is not
reality it's gonna be it may become
seasonal like the flu in which case
we're probably all going to get this at
some point in our lives so would it be
better for people who are speaking about
this publicly to simply say look the
purpose of what we are doing right now
is to avoid the overwhelming of the
health care system that's really what
this is about it's not preventing people
from getting infections in the long term
it's not preventing people from getting
this in receiving treatment the idea is
to delay because we weren't ready for
this and then to ramp up production
using the ventilators and the mitigating
treatments that we have so that when
there's a second wave it's not as cruel
in the fall and then hopefully we get a
vaccine by sometime next year wouldn't
that be a more realistic way to go about
explaining to people what exactly we are
doing than the way that has been
generally explained which seems sort of
vague it's it's it's almost as though
well you know we're gonna we're gonna
flatten the curve and then everything's
gonna go away by September and that does
lead to some pretty significant
questions about the modeling yeah well I
mean if you listen if you listen closely
I think it has been said that the White
House Task Force at least and foul
cheese specifically as well as dr. Burks
that there is an anticipated second wave
if you want to call or or it is being
thought of as okay we're probably going
to get this somewhat like the flu in
terms of seasonal or at least again
so the real direction of health policy
in this is twofold it's not just not
overwhelmed the health care system it's
number one to save lives to protect the
people who are going to die and when we
look at just look at the New York data
okay New York data alone something like
1.5 percent of deaths are in people
without any previous underlying
condition okay so that's very impactful
on the decision making because we know
who's going to die there are exceptions
no one's saying there's no exceptions
but exceptions don't disprove the rule
so the number one goal is to stop people
from dying the number two goal is to
make sure that we don't overwhelm the
system so that we can take care of sick
people and so that we don't endanger our
healthcare provider network of doctors
and nurses and respiratory therapists
etc and so that to me I think the
appropriate policy is to have isolation
of the people who are vulnerable I mean
in a very strict way making sure that
people understand that there is a
strategic isolation going that is the
vulnerable and the people who interact
with it people who are sick everyone
who's sick absolutely must assume with
or without testing they should assume
they have the virus and then
proceeded in an isolation mode for the
two weeks that are recommended and
number three a prioritization of testing
so that means who should be tested
people who are in the hospital who have
the symptoms and are sick make sure they
have they they do or do not have this so
they can be isolated people that are
interacting with older people like
nursing home workers people in the
healthcare profession this is the that
are taking care of patients these people
need to be tested it's not true that
there's this urgent equally urgent need
to test everybody immediately that that
is not really that's a that's a bad
message I think to send up and the
second thing to understand is it if
you're sick and you otherwise healthy
you don't need to go into to seek
medical care you can call your doctor
but if you just have a mild fever or a
cough and you don't have shortness of
breath or high fever you should assume
you have the virus and stay home that
prevents overwhelming of the system
there is no urgent need for testing of
people just out of curiosity or fear we
should if you're sick again assume you
have it be isolated the goal here is to
really stop the people from getting it
who are vulnerable there there is a
topic that I think is worth knowing
about which is this idea of herd
immunity which means that there's a
societal benefit to have people who have
the disease meaning they're carriers
sort of get it and develop their own
immunity and the more people that have
that the virus ultimately does disappear
as is the case for every other virus
that we encounter and you know the the
other part of the equation that I didn't
mention is that we should not
underestimate the work being done on the
drugs that are being used in clinical
trials and we will start seeing results
this month meaning within a couple of
weeks perhaps even within one week I've
been told by one of the big companies
being testing testing the drug and
clinical trials in these drugs the
intravenous drugs by for instance
the Gilead drug is a life see if it
works and there's plenty of reason to
believe it will work there's no
guarantee it's not proven but it did
work in other coronavirus models
previous to this in animal models it
does have safety profiles proven already
and fundamental biology it should work
and if it works it will save lives and
the other drug that we hear a lot about
is the hydroxychloroquine with or
without the antibiotic ether myzel and
there is fundamental biology it's not
just some sort of strange anecdote
report there's fundamental reasons on
the mechanism of action of the drug why
this will work and so I think that's
another cause for optimism it's not a
steady state here we're not where I
believe there's reasonable optimism to
be held that we will be able to treat
the disease and given that over time
that changes what happens next in terms
of let's just say this comes back next
January February okay by then it's very
possible we will have drugs to prevent
people from dying and that changes the
whole equation so how would you rate the
the federal and state response of our
doctor Atlas in terms of responding to
this thing obviously there were
shortages event Slater's in New York the
government on a federal level been
warned for 15 20 years that they needed
to be producing more ventilators the the
mass stockpile was not renewed but how
would you sort of rate various responses
from state and federal governments on
this thing so far considering it as a
Black Swan event yeah okay I mean the
first before I even comment I would say
that there is no scenario whereby a
healthcare system would not be
overwhelmed by a massive need if for
instance if 200 million people needed a
ventilator tomorrow that's just not
going to happen that's not realistic
we're not going to be sitting there with
hundreds of millions of these machines
it's just impact on realistic and sort
of silly to contemplate that I would say
that there is a
you know a good but imperfect response I
mean the first issue was knowing as soon
as possible that there was something
serious going on and and that was
imperfect and it was it was imperfect by
our by our government and by our
officials because we didn't have the
information and we assumed we did and if
you look at the quotes by somebody who's
really been fantastic which is dr.
pouchy in the end of January he was
saying there's no problem here you have
to realize that the President and
luckily for us the president and the
government officials are not winging it
here they're going by what they're told
from public health and other experts so
you know decisions were made based on
flawed information and that information
was really Frank frankly lies coming out
of China and a lot of opps curation of
what happened so no one in the world was
prepared but I think we did implement a
pretty quick I think president Trump
implemented a pretty quick travel ban on
incoming China flights that was good I
wish there was a stronger and quicker
response to bans on incoming flights
from other centers of the infection
including Europe it's it's hard to do I
think that the response of our system
has been I think very good and I would
say that given that okay I'm not
minimizing that people are dying
probably tens of thousands of people
that's a huge tragedy but not everything
in retrospect is is that it was done
wrong certain things are insurmountable
I think we implemented the right
policies to try to at least immediately
capture the kind of containment mode of
isolating given we're not a society
where we're going to put people in jail
and bar them in their homes with
physical barriers I mean we're a little
bit different than some of the other
societies but I think we're arc our
response has been good with that we have
fantastic experts working on this
tremendous amount of uncertainty
you know models are fell
people are fallible I think our numbers
of capacity for critical care beds is
the highest in the world per capita and
at particularly per capita of people
vulnerable to die okay when you look at
the data which I have and you calculate
it we have anywhere from two to ten
times what every other country has okay
we're not sitting there with our pants
down I have an inadequate health care
system it's just that this is a very
very urgent situation in terms of
ventilators I mean yes you know it's a
it's a common concept that okay we don't
have enough ventilators on the other
hand I think we are short in the hot
spot of Manhattan there's no question
but we're mobilizing we have a very
nimble healthcare system compared to
other systems I'll give you an example
CMS just authorized waived a lot of
rules on ambulatory surgery centers
which we have which are mainly private
they're not government-run and we have
5,800 ambulatory surgery centers in the
country by far more than any other
country and why is that important
because a those places have ventilators
let's just say on the average the
estimate is five per ambulatory surgery
sir that's 29,000 ventilators right away
that have been freed up because elective
surgeries and elective uses of those
centers have been stopped other
countries can't do that we can shift and
move around things very quickly and we
are and we're relaxed rules on
ambulatory surgery centers by the way
for healthcare providers for admitting
people for more than 24 hours which was
forbidden before we've relaxed rules on
the use of nurse practitioners and
physician assistants to prescribe
medicine to do things that were they're
capable of but not really authorized to
do in a normal circumstance without
physician input we've authorized
distance you know distance monitoring of
patients so I mean there's a lot of
things being done that we can do and
have
and are doing because we are a nimble
non-government centralized health care
system I think we're you know we have a
lot of problems because it's it's a very
difficult new virus to deal with we have
the most innovative system in the world
our our system has the appropriate
incentives in place for drug development
for vaccine development and our private
entrepreneurs and private sector medical
technology system which is by far the
best in the world in terms of just
quantity as well as quality is working
very well on this our FDA is
streamlining I think you know
tremendously in getting through new
approvals new drugs new clinical trials
I mean there's so much going on that
people don't realize and I'm I'm very
confident that this a is temp is is
temporary biologically speaking that's
just simply factual and but B I'm
optimistic that this is going to be
controlled and we are going to get back
to work and less and less people are
going to die because of the way our
system operates last question on they on
the on the death rates and and the
models so we've seen models that suggest
anywhere from 36,000 people to 2.2
million people dying in the United
States where do you think that given the
measures that are currently being taken
by States and they probably are not
likely to let up I would say at this
point until May it seems sort of the
common denominator where do you think
that those numbers end up over the
course of say a year yeah I mean it's
obviously impossible to predict but I
would I would put it this way when you
look at the models they've been coming
down significantly from the original
models and there's a reason for that the
original models were worst-case
scenarios and they assume that nothing
was going was being done we know that
this isolation works so when you look at
the model that the government is really
using which the the sort of average of
the
change of prediction in that model by
Murray and others is roughly in the u.s.
maybe 80,000 or so deaths which is
dramatic and huge and tragic for all the
reasons that of course we know with the
range of really being in the order of 30
to maybe 100 and some thousand and so my
guess as we proceed in again you know
nobody really can predict is we're going
to see more and more cases by virtue of
more and more testing and by virtue of
spread also we're going to see a lower
and lower fatality rate on the order of
under 1% I think that's highly likely if
now already proven and we're going to
see you know I'm hoping we see tens of
thousands of people die in the United
States as a maximum and the perspective
on that can also be ascertained from
looking at the modelers a different
group of modelers who came out with this
first estimate that you mentioned 2.2
million in the u.s. 500 thousand in the
UK they changed in three days to saying
20 thousand in the UK instead of five
hundred thousand and so the models are
fluid this is not a criticism of the
modelers this is understanding that the
the inputs are really making all kinds
of assumptions and those those inputs
change dramatically I want to put it a
little bit about perspective on this and
this is not at all to be minimizing
anything I don't want anyone any viewer
to interpret this as a minimization but
when you look at the number of deaths
from the flu every year in the United
States we have between thirty and sixty
thousand people died in the u.s. thirty
to sixty thousand people died in the US
every year from the flu 600,000 people
in the world died from the flu per year
roughly and so
it's a tragedy it's horrible but we do
have to realize that if we get out of
this with under a hundred thousand
people dying it's it could have been a
lot worse and was projected to be a lot
worse and we will move forward this will
end
dr. Atlas gonna do a quick lightning
round with you five questions
specifically if you have to set an end
date for this particular crisis when
people start to go back to work what
what do you think the end date is when
people start to go back to work here
okay it's a guess but I'm thinking
there's going to be a reentry into the
workforce sometime early summer what do
you think America is gonna look like six
months from now do you think we're all
gonna be wearing masks are we all gonna
be socially distancing still are all the
concerts in the and the and the sports
leagues gonna be closed still what do
you think America looks like I think
we're going to have some sort of new
normal which might involve some sort of
testing before group events I could see
that happening I I think many people
wear masks it's their choice I'm I'm not
a I don't think there's sound medical
evidence to use general population masks
and I do not think that that warning by
the way was absent because of some kind
of shortage that's not the reason it's
medical science so I don't think that
but I think a lot more people will be
wearing masks
what can America do to prevent the the
next pandemic from happening I think
we're going to be more prepared this one
this has really heightened the alert
we're going to see another one we've
seen this is the third since 2003 2004
there's no question we will see another
one I think this is really going to be
much we're going to try to be more
prepared we're going to learn from this
not just with vaccines but technology to
generate new drugs and vaccines the the
infrastructure and also and I'm involved
with a big a big effort now making sure
we we understand that health security is
national security how should we treat
China after all of this considering the
lies that they told considering the fact
that if they had let everybody know what
was going on that we probably prevent
according some studies 90% and 95% of
all casualties from this thing how
should the the world health community
treat China you know I think that China
I think this sort of opens people's eyes
I hope it opens people's eyes to what
what the economists have known all along
which is that their economic numbers are
not to be believed this is clearly
nothing they're saying about how many
cases they have or anything is to be
believed they did something really
heinous here in covering this up I think
China is is has really lost a tremendous
amount of credibility in in the rest of
the world and and I think that changes
their position tremendously and by the
way I think a lot of other countries
will be understanding they cannot depend
on China for a lot of things including
buy goods and finally the measures that
were taking now on a personal level the
sort of social distancing no handshaking
staying away from elderly people more
are those gonna be temporary or do you
expect those to be permanent I think
those are going to be temporary I think
we'll be more conscious of things and
we'll be conscious of it just like we we
have been in the past with the flu
getting flu immunizations everyone
should get that everyone will get these
immunizations I think there'll be a new
normal but it will it will fade into a
near-normal dr. Alice really appreciate
your time in your insight thank you so
much for your hard work and stay safe
outdoor in there is the case may be okay
thanks very much
now that we've heard the public health
perspective let's turn to the economy
bringing us the economists point of view
is Mohamed el-erian the chief economic
adviser to financial services company
Allianz and president-elect of Queens
College at the University of Cambridge
he's the senior adviser at Gramercy and
professor of practice at Wharton
he's an opinion columnist for Bloomberg
and has authored the only game in town
and when markets collide Oh Mohamed
great to see I'm glad that you and your
family are safe thanks so much for
joining us so let me start by asking you
about the sort of balance that we have
to draw between public health and
economic need there's this weird dynamic
that crops up mostly on Twitter where
one side of the debate suggests that the
economy is real life and therefore we
should sort of ignore the public health
warnings after all is this worth losing
tens of millions of jobs and tens of
trillions of dollars and on the other
side you have people who are saying if
we even save one life then we have to
all walk down for the rest of time as an
economist how do you determine where
exactly these sorts of lines should be
drawn how we create these balances and
thank you guys for having me look there
is an inherent contradiction and that's
why you get what you mentioned an
inherent contradiction between what this
phase of the health policy is social
distancing separation isolation and what
the economy is wired for and the economy
and society are both wired for
connectivity integration so there is
this tension that's playing out and
understandably so I think you have to
think about this sequentially it's not
an either-or is just a sequence over
time where our number one is to get
control of the virus contain and spread
tweet the ill better and hopefully
increase immunity until we get the first
two things done
it's going to be very hard to restart
this economy without going into W you
start and then you have to come down
again and we don't want it W having said
that we have to protect the economy and
this stage is about relief about
containing the damage and they'll come
in next stage which is going to be about
trying to return the economy to some
sense of normals
so I want to ask you about the release
measures they've been taken in just a
second but you've been looking at the
same models that I've been looking at
you know the models from University of
Washington or the Imperial College
models and one of the problems I have in
looking at the models especially when
we're thinking in terms of the economy
is trying to figure out when people go
back to work
it's pretty difficult when these models
end in August you know nobody seems to
be taking into account what happens in a
second wave nobody seems to be
suggesting what level of medical
capacity will have to be in September in
order for us not to go back into that
w-shaped lockdown that you've talked
about and so it makes it almost
impossible to determine at what point we
have a metric of success from from an
economists point of view what would a
metric of success look like such that we
could have a permanent return to the
workforce for at least a segment of the
population so Ben you zeroed on an issue
that's going to come up I suspect in
everything we discussed today which is
we don't know there's lots of things we
don't know we are learning as we go
along this is a shock that was
unthinkable if you happen like me when I
was young when I was your age I worked
on a fragile and failed economy I saw
what that looks like most people haven't
we've never seen a sudden stop hit us at
a level of the country as a watt as a
whole let alone the global economy so
we're learning in crisis management mode
we are basically trying to keep a plane
in the air while trying to build engines
and figuring out what to do with it so
this is what yeah I don't know what the
answer is I don't think anybody knows
what the answer is the key issue here is
to have an open mindset to be able to
make trade-offs and to be honest about
the trade-off for making because we're
gonna make some trade-offs and we're
gonna make some mistakes I want to talk
about how long realistically speaking
from an economic perspective we can we
can last like this so we've had a a fond
economic stop globally I mean the United
States we're going to see unemployment
rates like we've literally never seen in
American history we're going to see
people thrown out of their jobs it's
going to give the lie to the myth that
companies somehow have safes full of
cash in their back rooms that they're
just withholding from the group it's
because everybody's gonna go basically
bankrupt within within the next few
weeks because it turns out that's not
how companies actually operate how long
can we just keep floating along on on
basically taking out a credit card when
nobody is gonna buy our debt I mean it's
a bunch of countries that are selling
their debt to each other at this point
how long is that sustainable before you
start to see shortages before you start
to see no underlying economic activity
have the sort of permanent significant
impacts on the economy that we just
can't recover from so first it's gonna
be horrific it's gonna be worse than
anything we are the scene and and
there's no hiding this and we have to be
honest with the American people that we
are facing a very difficult economic
outlook that will make the sense of
health and security feel compounded by
economic and security and I wish I could
have another message Ben but that's a
reality already we've seen 10 million
people unemployed 10 million we are
concealed an opponent waste like would
never see and there's nothing better we
can do about it except if we decide to
sacrifice the health issue now the good
news is relative to every other country
in the world we can manage this awful
journey a lot better not smoothly but a
lot better why is that because we are
part of a neighborhood that's been hit
hard so we have better capacity to avoid
the things you said shortages avoid
temporary problems becoming permanent
ones and we've got to get money to
people quickly now we're gonna make
trade-offs that you and I don't like I
can tell you right now we're not gonna
like what we're gonna do but in crisis
management
you've got to contain the crisis first
and then try to clean things up we have
that ability but it's gonna it's not
gonna be perfect there's gonna be a lot
of casualties out there and then you and
I shall talk later this is not just
about winning the war and it is a war
this is also about winning the peace and
what we learned in 2008 9 that if you
don't win the peace you'd come out
fragile and we gotta avoid that so let's
talk now about the relief efforts that
have been attempted here so Congress
obviously passes the largest spending
package in the history of the world two
trillion dollars the Federal Reserve is
injecting another four trillion dollars
into the system so for folks who don't
understand exactly what Congress did
here and what the Federal Reserve did
here what exactly did Congress do what
exactly did the Federal Reserve do so
the Federal Reserve practice
and so far has been successful it crisis
that originated in health and paralyzed
the economy from creating a financial
crisis we came this close this close
been on a Monday two weeks ago to having
both in 1930s like depression and having
in 2008 like global financial crisis
became disclosed and the Fed simply had
to flood certain segments of the market
because the Treasury market the senior
market of the mother of all markets the
most senior market in the world was
dysfunctional and that means that the
pipes were clogged I know we don't pay
attention to the pipes and many many
people watching this will say I don't
know anything about the pipes but do you
know in your house when the pipes are
problematic you have a major problem and
we came this close to replace pipes
Claudia that was a Fed Congress and
administration are trying surveillance
completely they're trying to stop
short-term problems from becoming
long-term solvency issues let me let me
give an example a company right now
cannot sell anything it's your
restaurant if you are cutting hair
whatever you have no earnings it doesn't
mean you can't cut hair in future it
just you can't do it now
it's a liquidity problem if you don't
deal with your liquidity problem you go
bankrupt and what happens when you go
bankrupt lots of bad things happen and
the productive capacity of the whole
economy contracts which means we hit
ourselves now and we health it hit us up
in the future that is what Congress and
the White House are trying to do it's
not easy because many pipes aren't they
so when we talk about the Federal
Reserve buying up commercial paper or
backing bank loans it seems to me one of
my recommendations early on was that the
the first chief response here should be
to prevent the banks from being forced
to call in all of the loans from being
forced to call in the mortgages from
seeing the sort of stuff we saw in
2007-2008 instead it looks like the
government is going to start floating
basically direct loans to to businesses
as opposed to via via banks but do you
think would be better to go via the
banks or do you think that it would be
better
to start giving out directly loans via
the government as some have called for
so both okay and I think the banks are
under pressure not to do what she said
and there have been provided massive
relief massive relief they have had
constraints on them taken off I can go
through them but they they're very
technical and there's no excuse for the
banks not stepping up to their
responsibilities and I think they really
want to be part of the solution because
they were part of the problem last time
around and when it comes to the
possibility of inflation so a lot of
people been worried deeply about what
comes due on the other end of this so
obviously we've been spending out of
control for literally decades at this
point we just added six trillion dollars
presumably to the national debt over the
course of about three weeks here is
there the appetite for debt out there
has to be fairly low considering that
literally every other country in the
world is incurring its own set of debts
so is this going to be a situation where
the United States is either going to
have to radically raise taxes two years
from now or where we are going to have
to radically inflate the currency so
there's three issues here first
the inflation risk yes it is going up
this period we've lived with we haven't
had to worry about inflation and to the
extent that the policymakers did was
because inflation was too low that has
gone away we are going to have high
inflation coming out of this that's part
of winning the piece is understanding
that this is we have to deal with this
and why because when we we start the
economy which will do you and I will
want to buy things much faster than
there will be available so we're gonna
put pressure demand is gonna recover
before supply to us so we could have
inflation second issue no we're not
gonna have problems selling the dead you
know I call it the cleanest dirty shirt
you and I are you know we anybody's on a
trip the trip is extended suddenly
because the Allies don't fly we can't
get to a laundry we've gotta wear shirt
we're gonna wear the cleanest dirty
shirt
we are the cleanest dirty shirt by far
in the world so we will be able to sell
out that we have the reserve currency
however we are gonna come out of this
with a wheely deep entanglement of
government and private-sector activity
it will be a spaghetti ball but you and
I will be talking about this it's going
to be a messy
spaghetti ball because all these things
are being done ad hoc way has crisis
management and we've got to sort that
out pretty quickly otherwise the dad
element in itself the deep entanglement
of government and private activity will
pull down our growth potential so can
you talk a little bit about that what
specifically that give an example do you
mean by by that sort of entanglement
that we should worry about because I
think there are there are a lot of
people who are you know fiscally
conservative like I am who say well my
goal as soon as the things over us to
get government the hell out of this as
fast as humanly possible since
government obviously had a terrible job
preparing for it and then I sort of
believe the government is a giant
lumbering idiot and that doesn't mean
you don't need a giant lumbering idiot
every so often to intimidate people to
stay in their homes but it does mean
that you want it out of a more nimble
private sector as fast as possible what
does that entanglement look like coming
out of this so let's take bailouts okay
that's a perfect example so we've
already identified Boeing and the
airlines as recipients of bailouts we
did so because they were at the front
end of this closest there was this
notion that they exceptions they're not
exceptions and leading indicators right
every sector I know except for a few are
having a simultaneous destruction of
consumption and production so the line
for bailouts is gonna be very very long
so if you embarked on a bailout strategy
without having cleared principal who
even a bailout why are you gonna bail
them out how long for on what term and
what the exit policy is you end up with
a spaghetti bowl and the danger is now
what is sorry what is that spaghetti
ball okay so Boeing survives because of
government help so what's the
government's claim on Boeing when they
when they recover how long should that
you should the government be an equity
holder in Boeing where should it be when
it's other equity holder none of this
has been discussed and this has to has
got to be sorted out would it be better
in your opinion to avoid that that sort
of spaghetti ball if if the government
were just providing basically zero
interest loans to these firms as opposed
to trying to grab chunks of them we saw
Boeing actually turned down the
possibility of government
ownership in a statements it will fire
people before we allow the government to
run our business if you're if you're
trying to encourage businesses to keep
people employed one of the questions
I've had about the bill that Congress
passed is the interference in how
businesses are run the idea that if
you're a small business that we're gonna
float your loans specifically so you can
maintain your employment base but as
you've said there is literally no market
for your employees to cater to so would
it not be better for the government to
provide zero interest loans to companies
via banks that can assess risk and then
to just increase the unemployment
insurance on the other side so that we
are not actually providing incentives
for companies to keep people on the
payroll and then the minute that this
thing ends fire everybody which is
presumably what will happen because the
market is not gonna recover
simultaneously with with the end of this
pandemic so they're trying to stop that
by saying if you keep them on some of
your existing loans you're gonna get are
gonna be forgiven but you raise a
critical point if I was to play it again
you know what the the Monday morning
quarterbacking is really tempting but
I've been in crisis management
situations you're making it you are
making decisions with imperfect
information and you're making it up as
you go along and that's what happened
with this sue trillion dollar package
and and having a T ahead of the rest of
it makes us really worried because
that's a really large number was
unthinkable just three months ago um
look you ways to issues that I wish in
the next phase because there will be a
next phase implementation we think about
one is incentive alignment you talk
about incentive alignments it's really
important to us to align public and
private sector incentives and the second
one that is as important when you do
this is behavioral science understand
how people respond and neither of these
things have informed enough the design
of the program for understandable reason
but they must inform the implementation
because we are going to learn as we go
along and we have to have an open
mindset we I keep on telling people when
you deal in massive uncertainty you're
gonna make mistakes no one wants to make
a mistakes but you're gonna make a
mistake make sure we can learn quickly
and corrected most mistakes are
recoverable is the failure to learn from
this mistake that makes it non
recoverable
we must avoid that thing so you're
warning for years that the use of
central banks as the as the chief
policymakers in in finance was gonna be
a large-scale mistake because
governments were basically avoiding
their responsibility
we had already brought the interest
rates down to extreme lows in the United
States even leading up to this which
meant that there was just less water in
the hose now there may have been enough
water in the hose to forestall something
for the moment but looking forward to
the future is that failure to to abide
by actual policy making across countries
not just in the United States but in but
in Europe as well and the overuse of
central banks as chief policymakers has
that watered down the ability of central
banks to do what they need to do and is
it gonna make the recovery a lot steeper
on the other end yes and yes and it's
really unfortunate because this was an
avoidable mistake you know I wrote this
book in 2016
called the only game in town and and the
last bit of it was avoiding the next
collapse and I argued then and the book
an update of the book is coming up I
argued then that within five years we
will come to what I call the t-junction
that the path we were on that we lied
only on central banks would plant the
seeds of its own destruction and then we
would have to make a choice
turn towards better policy genuine
growth genuine financial stability none
of the artificial stuff that we've done
or alternatively recession and financial
stability and I argued that the
vulnerability to a shock was very high I
never imagined the shock would be as big
as this man never imagined but now it
caught us weak it caught us fragile our
ability to recover is going to be less
strong because of that and that's what I
meant about coming out of the global
financial crisis we didn't win the piece
we just won the war we didn't wind it
and this time around we've got to be
much more forceful you and I can talk
for the whole show about how different
the post-crisis landscape is gonna look
like let's prepare for it now so let's
talk about that what will the
post-crisis landscape look like and how
exactly do we prepare for it there was a
lot of talk early on when this first
broke this is gonna be a v-shaped
recovery okay so everybody loses their
job for a month and then we
go back to work and it's basically
summer vacation except paid for by the
government but obviously that is not the
case they're doing some permanent
landscape shifts and how the economy
works I mean at least for the next year
at restaurants the entertainment
industry movies sports how office
buildings work all of this is is going
to change what does the the Pro the
post-crisis landscape look like and how
do we win the piece so I have a I have a
piece of paper here where I keep on
writing down how a difference going to
look I I went out of one side I started
the second side we they look very
different very different if you're a
company you're gonna swing from
efficiency to resilience you're gonna
set forget all about this just-in-time
inventory management forget about these
globalized supply chains I want to
increase my resilience so we're gonna
dig low belies the world households are
going to become much more cautious they
are going to increase the precautionary
savings so we're going to see is change
in household behavior we are going to
see a change in work practices you just
mentioned some of them we're going to
see a change in so many things we do
institutions are gonna come at this
battered our trust in the establishment
is gonna be even weaker after this um so
that's gonna be lots of thing we are
gonna have massive debt we would have
lowered our productivity because we're
gonna rewire the economy and when Yuri
why the economy productivity goes down
so I ability to afford that there will
be less central banks will have massive
balance sheets that we need to deal with
just to give an example in two weeks
alone we've increased the balance sheet
by over exfoliant dollars and like you
said four trillion expansion is on the
cars that is that is incredible so it is
a very different landscape we can manage
it but we have to plan from now okay
the aftermath of the crisis is going to
be as important as what seems pretty
horrible now so how do we plan for stuff
like that so to take for an example you
mentioned the breaking of global supply
chains now they're gonna be a lot of
firms that look at China for example and
say we're not locating
because of what just happened but
presumably there will be one or two
firms that say okay well the risk is the
reward is worth the risk I'm gonna
undercut my competitors by continuing to
manufacture them from China and hope
that for five or ten years there's not
another wet market a prick like this and
and so without any sort of sort of
government measure that prevents people
from undercutting one another by taking
that riskier supply chain line are those
changes going to be permanent or is is
the institutional memory here gonna be
short so I think it's gonna be permanent
and again we all have a role to play the
last thing you and I want for our kids
is the notion that any company is
international when it makes profit and
national when it fails okay because if
it means that in you know when it is
making profit everybody else benefits
and when it fails they come to us the
taxpayer okay so there has to be
incentive to stop people abusing this
notion that you can be international
when everything is going well and then
you become national when things go bad
so we can do this again these are about
tax incentives we can do this you just
have to realize that that's the world
were going into and we have to abuse do
we have to stop the abuse that you
talked about so let's talk about the
stock market for a second you've
mentioned before you were ahead of the
curve as you very often are on this sort
of stuff when the stock market started
to drop and people were saying now's a
great time to buy you were saying well
wait a second because it's gonna drop
some more how far do you think that
stock market is gonna drop you don't
have to put a number on it but but how
long do you think it's going to drop
given the the uncertainty have we
reached sort of baseline uncertainty and
now the news starts to get better or do
you think that the uncertainty continues
for months and months and months and is
this a buying opportunity or should we
all just sort of sit on on whatever cash
we have in our in our hands so I think
it's a ladder I think it's still time to
be there courses and I've gone out of my
way so my social media and my
publications expire increase the amount
of information going to retail investors
a small investor in particular because
they tend to say of this industry is it
then you buy buy buy buy buy okay
because they make these when you buy
look go back to the uncertainties we are
just about understanding the severity of
this short we have no idea what the
situation
we don't quite understand in the
marketplace that is going to take time
for the relief measures to work we
certainly haven't incorporated in the
marketplace that the we start isn't
about turning on a button then turning
on the switch and none of these things
that you and I have talked about about
the post-crisis landscape is bison so we
are still at an early phase I tell
people expect a volatility around a
declining trend for now and realize that
in such an uncertain environment you can
likely make a mistake no one wants to
make a mistake but you're gonna make a
mistake
ask yourself what mistake can you afford
to make is it missing the 5% jump
immediately when the bottom is formed or
is it avoiding another 10 to 15 percent
or regret minimization in my mind is
what should lead investment policy make
sure you minimize your regrets for most
of us that means it's better to be too
late
back into the market too early so we you
mentioned earlier there there may come a
time when we have to make hard choices
with regard to the economy there right
now we can afford to take the public
health hit based on the modeling that we
can all hope that the summer kills this
thing off that we have measures in place
by September but it's pretty obvious
that we can't do this indefinitely we're
already starting to see some rioting in
southern Italy we've already seen talk
about the EU breaking up and only a few
weeks into this thing one of the things
that's been bothersome about some of the
experts in public health talking about
this sort of stuff is the models they
put out there will assume things like
we're all going to remain home for the
next year or 18 months which obviously
is not true so when does economically
speaking the pedal hit the metal what
does it basically make or break point
where if we don't at least start getting
people back to work then the house of
cards completely collapses is there a
point where we basically have to say if
it's a choice between the economy and
public health we just have to choose the
economy or there will no there will be
no more economy left to choose so
everybody will tell you being
risk-averse doesn't mean not taking any
risk okay it means taking calculated
risk and we do this all day long we take
calculated risk when we cross the street
we take a calculated risk if we if we
we're completely risk-averse
across the street so at some point we're
gonna get to to a stage where you're
gonna have to take a calculated risk in
my opinion it's gonna be when we have
gotten control we've understood how this
virus spreads it's gonna be when we have
testing facilities out there when we are
better at identifying who has it and
finally when we can keep the l better
when we have ventilators except when we
get to that stage we can start talking
about taking calculated risk and we're
gonna have to because you're right if we
shut down the economy for a year for two
years the Cure is gonna end up being
just as bad as what got us here okay
because when you shut down the economy
it's not just about economic and
security it's about domestic violence
it's about social unrest
it's about all these other things that
we also have to take into our time we're
not there yet and we we have time but if
we don't get our arms around this
horrible virus we're gonna have some
pretty massive trade offs and my great
fear is that now's the time when we
should be listening to experts but it's
also a time when experts are able to
provide us less information than out
here their time so we have this sort of
sort of backwards behavioral problem
which is the we have to listen the
experts to stay home but they can't
provide us enough information that
causes us to stay home other than
providing these certain numbers and when
you say to people stay home indefinitely
and meanwhile people are losing their
jobs I wonder how long that can last
indefinitely speaking I mean I wonder if
if six weeks from now when the checks
still have not arrived and when people's
bills are still do whether they just say
to the experts listen you're not even
providing us an end date here you can't
tell people to diet indefinitely you
have to tell them what the end date of
the diet is otherwise people start
ignoring the dietician correct
I was called adjustments fatigue that at
some point we get tired and the biggest
risk we face as a society is the lag
effects so we do it we have made every
single American is making massive
sacrifices right now by staying home yes
they're trying to protect their health
but they are also losing jobs those who
are employed are getting
the income cut so massive sacrifice and
what I worry about most is because the
lagged effects of the so-called curve is
at least two to three weeks at some
point we are going to say collectively
or parts of us hey wait a minute you
mean I've made all these sacrifices and
I haven't flattened the curve obviously
leaders don't know what they're doing
and we're not going to realize that
there was a lag effect there so it's
it's gonna be hard and this adjustment
fatigue is serious
I tell people you've gotta provide
honest information um I don't know Ben
if I may but I'll give an example when
my girls came home they were really
unsettled so what we decided to do is
every day we would sit down and talk
about what's happening on the corner
virus and importantly what to expect
what to expect and this notion of I
don't know for sure but they saw what
I'm looking for has helped people
enormously because they give them a
world map we do not have a sufficiently
clear world map on health and we have no
world map on the economy and we've got
it shared both with the American people
otherwise they do you know they create
their own world maps and if you're
worried about the expert not being
informed we individually I don't have
cooked you know it's another spaghetti
bowl of log mats and we can't have that
Mohammed I have five questions for a
quick lightning round and so number one
how should the world treat China after
this obviously China did not shut this
thing down they lied to the w-h-o if
they had revealed this information a
month in advance there's some studies
that suggest 95% of all casualties could
have been avoided so how should the
world treat China after this I've heard
suggestions from people that I don't
think are you know doable like we should
just cancel our debt to China how should
we deal with with China and what sort of
reparations should China be forced to
pay for that for what what has been
incurred here so starting with the trade
war I think we've emerged from this
happy talk that China is a global
responsible player China is not a global
responsible player China does not play
to the global rules and we haven't held
China accountable for a very long time
we should continue to hold China
accountable and we should do it it with
our allies but this is a moment to say
enough is enough
we've tolerated intellectual property
theft we've tolerated alsa we will not
tolerate you being part of the export of
a virus so I think we got a whole China
much more accountable to his global
responsibilities now that we've allowed
it to be part of the global economy will
the measures that we are now taking be
temporary or permanent this is my great
fear is that people tend to use crises
as an opportunity to confirm their
priors and when it comes to the growth
of government we've never seen anything
like this and so quick a time are the
measures that we are taking now
expedience or do you think that these
become a permanent feature of the
American landscape so I like you worried
about short-term edges becoming
long-term measures okay that's why we
have to think about this very carefully
as we implement it I looked at risk is
there and we've got to collectively make
sure that it doesn't reach critical mass
because if it does then our longer-term
prosperity would be threatened what can
we do to prevent a couple things that we
can do to prevent this kind of economic
meltdown
next time a a Black Swan event hits like
this so we need to develop three things
that we haven't developed resilience the
ability to live through sharks and that
starts at the government level the
household level and the corporate level
to optionality this ability to change
our minds as we get better information
don't get stuck on an old model and
finally agility the good news and I
think there are silver lining is when we
emerge from this we are going to have a
opportunity set for this country that we
have not had before and we need the
agility to respond it will look
different but we have the best initial
conditions been to respond with agility
and be able to bounce back not fully but
certainly faster than we would otherwise
what do you think America will look like
six months from now I'm worried I'm
worried I think six months from now
there's a big there's a big chance that
our economy is still hit hard that we
have pockets of social unrest
and I'm worried this is gonna be a hard
journey it's one of these things you
know it's like taking your kids on a
trip even if you're going to Disneyland
if it's an 11 hour car journey they're
gonna
and attorney really long and at some
point you you you fed up with hearing
are we there yet are we there yet are we
there yet okay I'm afraid that that's
what's gonna look like the journey is
gonna be horrific and I'm worried that
our social the social fabric is gonna be
really stressed so prior to all of this
obviously the stock market was at
all-time highs unemployment was at
all-time lows how long do you think it
is before we return to those sorts of
numbers so on the unemployment side a
long time a long time because certain
businesses aren't going to come back and
people are gonna have to retool and I
you know I'm worried about this and I
hope you know I I make predictions and I
normally hope I'm right this time around
I hope I'm completely wrong on all these
predictions I hope it turns out that it
is a V that we simply flick on a switch
and this is just a bad nightmare but
it's gonna take a long time and same
with the markets we've come from it from
a very special period but we're being
hit with a deadly virus that's gonna
create permanence cause well Mohamed I
really appreciate your time I really
appreciate and say stay safe out there
or in there as the case may be great to
talk to you you too Thank You Ben as
always folks I really appreciate you
watching and listening stay safe out
there
or in there as the new phraseology goes
and we'll see you here next week this is
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike joiner and produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer case Winterton
our guests are booked by Caitlyn Manor
post-production is supervised by Alex's
Singaram editing is by Jim Nichol audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia Angulo the venture Pierrot show
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]